it's wednesday the 27th of may
another day in [ __ ] solitary
confinement thank god
uncle joey's here to save the day kick
this [ __ ] mu lee
oh [ __ ] it all starts [ __ ] today no
more [ __ ]
[Music]
27. you're in for another month hot
sucker so count it off
it's a beautiful wednesday to be alive i
got one of my favorite people
in studio i got the mask on we'll talk
more about it
you know sometimes you got to do the
zoom but it's so [ __ ] impersonal
if you're willing to come in you don't
give a [ __ ] about covid whatever
you come in we talk like man my brother
uh professor extra now
community leader mr alberto crane what's
going on brother
thank you thank you for having me always
good to see you
great always good to see you i've been
watching when
you know when i was going to your jiu
jitsu program
you introduced me a lot to technical
fitness little things
and one day i actually something
occurred that
made me go wow there's something to this
every exercise so when this break came
i started hitting bags and [ __ ] in my
backyard
but my stress level was so hard
my my fear had gone into my psyche
that something made me use the club
weights i went to kettlebells and my
back hurt
started doing club weights and then i
just started breaking my wrist and
moving my neck around now you told me to
do it in the front seat of a plane
and move it around and and just move
your wrist and
and it was just seemed uh interesting
and i said i got into you i i got into
rob miller at nine
but he's swinging like [ __ ] mickey
mantle bats and [ __ ]
you know he's got like this bat
you gotta hit like a gorilla with it to
kill him jeez
you know like they're like 85 pound bats
robs give it a minute
lighten up with the pasta and then andy
could look
the guy that teaches kickboxing i don't
know what planet he's on
he disappears he throws my name just
disappears
because the skinny white guy comes into
the picture but the only guy who's
really laying down
the tactful is you and i called you and
i said i appreciate what you're doing
because
i got so sick of doing kettlebells that
i started doing
the swings the nickel belt right there
and then i started doing a real bond
burner with the 50
between your legs swing up squat show
the park squat
yeah squid up and i started doing those
things 20 minute timer
keep going then i do i throw the
kettlebells in a farmer walk
a couple cleans maybe some high pulls
with a 45 pound kettlebell bent over
rows
end up with some curls a lot of
stretching
and that's good enough you hear you
don't freak out at night
that's better than nothing so i've been
calling you
torturing you about your videos stop
looking at the [ __ ] camera the [ __ ]
because he teaches something look what
are you looking at
this ain't jacqueline did you ever see
jacqueline look at something no
you could have showed jacqueline 18
black [ __ ] he wouldn't have stopped
you don't stop you keep going but they
kneel they look
like alberta you're killing me i'm in
the room i'm trying to burn calories i'm
a fat [ __ ]
so so i called you up and you were
talking and you said that you had this
thing coming out you wanted to come on
and then we spoke about the covid and
you said to me
um yeah i tested positive for the
antibodies right so
when did you do the test when or when
when
uh so i did it uh maybe like this last
night
i would have made you what just wanted
to know you know i got sick like in uh
january february yeah so i got really
sick and
you know around the gym everybody had
this like dry cough it seemed like
all the symptoms that everybody had so
just for peace of peace of mind
i wanted to know um and so you know i
went
i went to this place they did the
antibody testing and uh
and uh yeah they i tested i tested
positive for all the antibodies meaning
that i had it you know
well you know who knows right who knows
because who knows how accurate they are
they're always changing changing the
opinions right
um and then the the interesting thing
was that they said a third of the people
that have gone in there and now they
have had it you know have had it like
they stick that thing all the way
up your nose no it's a different one
it's a blood test i don't like that
thing yeah yeah
so they do the blood test and so they
just see what they
took the needle what's that what it is
in your arm
or whatever you want maybe no they they
take out
like uh well they didn't even more than
just little time a little bit yeah more
than that
as soon as i see any of the vaccines i'm
willing to die
i don't want no needle she understands i
don't know i know that this means a
needle
now i got a new chinese doctor i gotta
argue with him
you know dr wu and i gotta fight with
him because my old doctor retired
i'm gonna go down there because i don't
mind needle i worked myself
up to give blood from the arm everything
else is [ __ ] if you give me a shot
in the ass i got anxiety
and once you shoot that muscle in my arm
i see [ __ ] stars
so i detect this shot you don't see no
bats
like you might get it that's great but i
don't hang out with bats and [ __ ]
raccoons
i'll worry about every time lee laughs
the the mask covers his eye please
i just i'm just imagining him actually
having this conversation with his doctor
this [ __ ] hides food in this
mask you gotta see him again
you gotta cook it's a long day so i i
don't like none of that [ __ ] so
the tube in the nose that [ __ ] i'm not
adding me crazy
oh yeah was your wife a systematic
uh yeah she she didn't get sick the kids
get it didn't get sick you know
well they had systematic offer yeah they
didn't have uh
they didn't have any they didn't get
sick so they're sick of my house i think
there's two different things that we're
talking about
you have the antibodies which means you
have right right so then there's
asymptomatic which means you had it but
you didn't get sick
okay right so you can you can have covid
right supposedly who knows right with
all the information
like back and forth information but
right you can have symptoms or you
cannot have symptoms so what they said
actually were
a third of the people that have gone in
have a test deposit for the
for the antibodies meaning that they had
it some had no symptoms at all
some had some and some got you know
pretty sick
and can you get it again or no what do
they say i don't know they don't keep
going back and forth nobody really knows
anything the vaccines might work you
gotta wait for the vaccine but we don't
know if it's gonna work or not right you
were traveling a lot
for a while towards the end of the year
i went to in january i went to london
and there's like a thousand people there
i went to a conference with a thousand
people
shaking hands like crazy and then morals
were you before london
uh i went to brazil in uh i think in
february
that's where that got everybody that's
what invented
the brazilian was on the phone with
luhan when they invented that [ __ ]
man because it's going off from brazil i
mean
they keep wrestling who knows well who
knows what's really going on because i
have so many
friends in brazil and like it's like a
at this point it seems like it's very
like political you know i don't know
what's going on
that's the truth right but like my
friends in brazil
like in in the cities like the bigger
cities you know it's like
rio some i have a lot of friends in belo
horizonte which is the third largest
city
and the hospitals are empty there you
know and the major cities
is sao paulo and the other parties there
so they're kind of
hype it seems like they're hyping it up
i don't know though i don't know i'm
sorry you know if i don't mean to be
just
anybody but everybody is you know but uh
but
i i don't know i don't know i don't know
if i don't know if i can believe it or
not
and at this point after this these many
months the fact that we're questioning
what's going on i don't know it makes me
kind of like think twice like
what's going on right what's going on
you know like in georgia like the
i saw that the the governor is allowing
people to train jiu jitsu
and you know train again and you know
so i don't know i don't know what the
the right thing or you know
i'm being definitely being careful and
and uh trying to do my part you know i
was one of the first guys to
to close up my gym right before we had
to before was mandated
you know because i thought that was the
right thing um but
i don't know it's a difficult difficult
you know situation right
i mean that was my second big question
to you was
jiu jitsu is the opposite of social
distancing
you know what i'm saying like you know a
[ __ ]
is the opposite of transgender
you know a guy puts a guy puts mascara
on in a way
different story you go to a farm get
your dick cut off
and walk around then come see me you
know what i'm saying but you know
i love this analogy what's up
you know what is the plan for jiu jitsu
good question right well here's what's
gonna happen alberto
they're gonna this was gonna happen
unless you guys let it
or if alberto being the businessman that
he is
does not allow it you got two options
you got you you got to get on the phone
we could bring you
egan his brother
and say look we got to put together
something
if all folders get together we got to
put together something
as you and i know as in the comedy world
the egos
of b won't let that happen so alberto
has to worry about his children
and his wife and his kids i heard this
rumor that this will work okay
so you know white belts come in
uh i saw gsp defeat george sarah
i want to be a white belt okay you come
in
you start in the back room and you have
to bring a colbert test from your doctor
i mean that's that's basically you know
you have to have a special guy that
comes in at night
sprays that stuff now that's an extra
cost out of your pocket
into your pocket but as far as the guys
you have such a great nick community
family they'll listen to you
now i'm going to say this to you and
wink at the same time
you're going to i'm i'm the health
inspector i'm walking in there right now
and i'm going okay first technical
fitness
just like that park will put circles
yeah but i got 32 students in the circle
you could have 15 in this class you go
[ __ ] yourself
so i had a second class okay then
they're gonna go into the jiu jitsu room
and they're gonna go you and i both know
that
you know social distancing and me trying
to get you into [ __ ] ezekiel
is too big i'm breathing i'm sniffing
and [ __ ] farting
that's the whole thing how can we settle
this well
again all my students have to get
covered
uh you gotta you gotta hire a chinese
guy not a white guy
not not an armenian guy okay let me try
this guy
checked the temperature at the door yeah
we got a temperature check because we
these [ __ ] you and i both know
that you're rolling with somebody
awesome they tap for something they're
just a belt and they go
and you're like why did you come here
why the [ __ ] did you come here today you
know you're sick
come back on sunday now you have 30 day
suspension sundays only
you know you have so when that guy comes
you have to have your exes marked
of what area they're going to be in a
box tape
of where they're going to stay in and
now then you're going to take marco
who's a purple belt
a mediocre blue belt and a good brown
belt and
put them together and then alternate the
white belts
in and only those guys at first are
allowed to roll together
for the first six months if you have
everybody going crazy at once
you're going to have a breakout then
they're going to shut you down then
you're going to be selling
brazilian artifacts over there
[Music]
you know little drums for copper and
[ __ ] like that you want to do that
sell brazilian stamps so like everybody
i've talked to
that has gyms has been a little off i
get not getting the paycheck for four
months
and paying rent and going wow this is
costing me
but i also get opening up and getting 50
rather than 100 it's not even about it's
not even about the money right it's not
even about
the business it's like it's something
that's your life right it's like
it's something that who you are like
professor i would never focus money and
smoke in front of you but
you already got the copic who gives a
[ __ ]
i can smoke [ __ ] aid cigarettes at
this point
who gives a [ __ ] and i'm saying this
will be good for your lungs
well do you think that jujitsu is maybe
a little bit more prepared
because like i and i don't go obviously
but i gotta
notice from like 24 hour fitness how
they were gonna do it like you have to
sign up
for a certain block yeah so they're
going to clean that's it you know like
we're
we're gearing up you know we're gearing
up we're going to have everything in
place like
definitely uh special cleaning things uh
but you guys already cleaned like my
point was like you guys already have to
clean the mats a lot yeah yeah for sure
but was just even doing
some exercises i've been to a lot of
places alberto korean
cleans that mat the problem is now
you're gonna have to clean it
more every class put people's uh those
tubs around
so before people step on them exactly we
already got those in place
you know you got those in place yeah for
sure jiu jitsu is gonna really really
you know kickboxing
kickboxing boxing is you and i together
throwing punches at each other exhaling
and exhale inhaling
exactly what we don't want yeah we could
do it outside
with mascot when i walk into a gym the
door ain't open i walk out
the door's got to be open you know i'm
getting letters from all these airlines
lately
all of them are changing their multi-air
systems and
if you have air you don't you got four
[ __ ] doors
open that's fresh air yeah we got we got
some air air filters you know that
supposedly kill the
you know the the all the antibacterial
and whatever the
i don't have to look more that the
science but they supposedly
really cleans the air out you know so
just everything we can do
we're gonna have in place and you guys
or don't i would imagine
that when you do jujitsu you have to
sign a waiver
you have to get hurt so we have to have
special uh waivers you know covered
waivers
for sure and uh but the thing is like
going back to what i was saying like
it's not about the money it's not about
like the the for sure like you know yeah
like we've been closed for like on how
many months
i lost track of time how many months
it's been you know
but the fact that you know that we can't
do what you love to do that that's like
quit like who you are like
like what the [ __ ] you know like for the
last 29 years i've been out every night
you understand me and 10 before that i
was outspoken cold
getting syphilis getting my dick sucked
so for the last 39 years at 8 o'clock
i'm already looking at pants you know
looking at his shirt
i think i feel now again for me it's not
about the money
yeah it's not i'm kind of happy this is
giving your body a chance
yeah to rest sure really see what
direction you want to show
sure there has been a silver lining but
they have cut off our lifeline
which affects you every three days for
two days i
faked the funk i'm having a good time
you know
[ __ ] the armenians you know you have a
great time
and then one day you look at the mirror
and you're like right now at this time
i'd be getting ready to go to the comedy
store to go oh right now at this time
i'd be waking up getting ready to get on
a plane and it's real
yeah listen money comes and goes when
you learn that lesson in life that money
comes and goes this will make
your situation a lot easier you know how
you're getting unemployment
right now and you're getting that six
then they give you that five
you're jumping down like leads up on
dancing days
you're gonna have to pay back that
nickel i don't know if you've been told
that yet
so before you spend that nickel know
that all this money is coming back a lot
of it
so we're gonna have a lot of panic here
for a while
a lot of confusion but anyway back to
the jiu jitsu schools
the square
sign up classes and extra classes yeah
you
love it it's in your blood you can't
even imagine not doing jiu jitsu it
would have to be the end of the world
for a guy
it's gonna happen you know if i would be
a criminal if i gotta go to jail
[ __ ] arrest me you know arrest me i'm
ready don't take a [ __ ] bullet for it
you know that's how i feel
if i saw you in a body cast they just
lay you in class in the middle and you
just give directions put the leg over
there
i'll be doing it that's you yeah that's
right
and that's why you have the school you
have it's not really a school
it's a little community you've seen
people grow up there
people won world championships in there
you got the restaurant next door
it's like a little [ __ ] hang you got
a kickboxing thing over there
you got the kettlebell he's doing a
great job
that poor bastard joey alvarado 5 30 in
the morning
yeah i started calling that too ask them
collect calls we'll walk in the bakery
you gotta call them like it too hello
hello it's one there
there's no one here hangs up on you
you ever see those things it will like
wake up like
4 45 you know man i can't go to sleep
and you walk out you have your coffee
you sit down
you get your notebook out you put
youtube on also you know let me see
what's going on on facebook
it's [ __ ] coach alvarado jumping up
and down with seven other people
yeah doing kettlebells he says in 15
minutes kelly you're like
i think i'm right over there indoors a
quick 6 15 kettlebell class
and as i'm moving to the closet i go
listen if i was to pick up
a 35 pound bar right now this [ __ ] would
blow right out of my [ __ ]
like right out i could not handle a 35
pound
kettlebell at 5 30 in the morning that's
too much
that's dedication and he does them every
day
and he zooms them every day monday
wednesday and friday monday and saturday
night and saturdays
it's amazing yeah and you know what i
don't do his whole class
i don't do albertos whole uh whatever
class
i take two exercises that they do that
day and i incorporate them in the thing
some of them i can do some of them i
can't the one i really like is going on
the floor
picking up your legs and kicking up your
hips
a little bit of a body burner but not
bad i get up
i do the single opposite shoulders
and then i take two tens go up and do
the finisher
but then i take two 15s hold it and make
sure my arms lock up
and then and i make sure my wrists spin
that's it on the way
back to the flicker who do you think
you're dealing with just because i was
smoking
attention i love all of those
that's all the kids are like man are
these kids learning anything you know
because you
spend years with them and then all of a
sudden they like they know everything
perfectly
i do i still do my whole ground
technique you know
yeah yeah the shin box like this little
hip thing the shin box
i still do my shin box with the
finishing with me
on the wrist i still got the five pound
bat just to do the whatever i put my
back all the way towards the toilet
and i take two 15 pounds when i'm nice
and hot
and i [ __ ] just press them but this
direction instead of pressing overhead i
press them away
so my back is locked up into the [ __ ]
toilet
oh i go bananas i've been going bananas
lately because i know
you've been we've been you've been
calling me every week so i know you're
doing something i know that
we've lost half our movement just from
our lives
i tell you what you know when i'm the
hungriest when i do two shows at the
comedy store and i leave that
i'm [ __ ] starving sometimes i stop at
joe's
and get two slices of pizza i get a
peanut butter and jelly sandwich
sometimes i just make a haunted smoothie
you know
and it's amazing how i don't have that
appetite no more
yeah even because my body has slowed
down
that you know you've had stresses in
other places your mind is stressing
your mind distressing but your uh
your body so now it went from my account
all my points on weight watchers
yeah first three or four weeks of this
uh pandemic i was only working on 24
points
i could feel the heat like i was going
to have a stroke
and i changed it up and since the end of
[ __ ]
march i've been like a savage doing
farmer walks
cleans i got a bike let me tell you
something
you watch me on the bike i want to see
you i want to see you on that bike
oh my god i want to see that bike you're
on i like all these people who pay like
300 to see mike tyson
yeah yeah i could charge a nickel to
give you one ride on a bike
that'll change your life forever you
know what i'm saying uncle joey on a
bike
so are you optimistic about jiu jitsu
have you heard anything
ah you know i saw there was a po there
was a post today you know uh from hanzo
gracie
and he gave a shout out to the governor
of georgia you know
how he's the great great governor and
all that and he had they had jiu jitsu
classes the gyms were the first
thing to open and they have full-on
jiu-jitsu classes
so yes i do believe it's going to come
back because it's a it's a
talk about with everything's essential
or non-essential
if we're human it's men it's like it's
like happiness
it's like living you know yeah yeah for
mental health for
so many benefits the community you know
people like we live in this big city
with
millions of people but nobody's really
connected so those things are important
man for people to feel connected
and for happiness you know and uh moving
right all the things that we have there
to stay healthy you know this whole
fight-or-flight thing
everybody's talking about like you know
that have these fear things right but
nobody's talking about what they can do
to make their immune system stronger
their health right to if they do get
something they do get coveted or they
get something else that maybe it's even
worse
nobody's talking about that so you can
get over it right so you can take the
hit
and keep going you know and getting
recovered from it you know what i mean
that nobody's talking about that
nobody's marketing that
so what's going on here what's going on
here right
something's not right yeah at this point
yeah you're a jiu jitsu professor
well he's a [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] i
wanna call them this week i love them to
that
we don't know what's really going on all
i know is i respect my boundaries
i wear my face mask i do believe that in
crowds for some reason
and everything i've read it does take
off you know in places like
italy what happens in italy i live
i'm your brother i live in the basement
you live on the second floor with your
wife and the two kids on the third floor
your mother and father live
so if one of them brings us home
everybody gets sick that's why so many
families were dying
that's why so many people in new york
are running out of the city to buy
houses in northern new jersey even
though this
the suburbs are contaminated teen
identify
they're contaminated they're buying
houses they don't want to be in
buildings no more
sharing the same [ __ ] air ducts you
know
you know like you one one of the calls
that we had you're like i think i'm not
going to do comedy anymore you know
and family i mean that we're not comedy
but like uh you know
shows or what you know comedy shows
right you said you said something like
you're upset and you you kind of came
out you know i'm like
man like it upset me you know i was like
that's
that's [ __ ] you know it's like me
saying i'm not gonna do jiu jitsu
anymore
and uh and uh i'm like what's going on
here man
so much i just feel like there's so much
fear so much fear
that like are you kidding me like we're
going to stop being ourselves we're
going to stop living our lives like
every day is not guaranteed right
it's like the every day that i live like
i'm going to man
i'm not going to live and be in this in
this bubble i'm not going to
suppress my life right to
what's going on like the fact that we're
questioning what's going on like it
makes me think
right i was like yes sir i did
everything like i closed the gym
before we had to right and then you know
we i didn't nothing happened you know
but at this point like months in the
fact that we're questioning like we're
questioning what what
what what's really going on i don't know
man is it
real is it really that bad like i shared
with you that my dad
you know he's been on lockdown for the
last two months right and uh in a
nursing home his health isn't good so
he's
at most risk right guess what happens
two and a half weeks ago
my sister calls me he's got kovid right
okay he had a cough he was okay right
and so they brought him back to the nerd
he tested after two weeks he tested
negative okay
then they tested him again and he was
positive again so they took him again
because he was he went to vietnam he's a
green beret right so they took him to
the veteran hospital
and uh and uh and uh
the the the one he's in the he's in the
hospital again you know and so he's all
discombobulated
and so and now he has a urinary tract
infection
and it's in his blood and now it's
serious you know and it's not from kovid
it's from the neglect man
what's worse you know what's worse
and so as soon as he gets that negative
test we're taking him out he needs like
24-hour care you know and so we're gonna
take we're gonna take him out you know
we have to figure it out it's so weird
how much i thought about jiu jitsu
when this whole thing started
because it just lets you know about our
human nature and who we are
so for the first week let's say march
16th and 17th and 18th
i decided that i would go to north
hollywood park
park my car get out smoke a joint and
then walk around the park
and then i started seeing something by
the third day i started saying that even
with social distancing guidelines in
order
you had people still four feet apart
you had people still coming close to me
plus i was walking behind people people
would be running and i'd be walking
behind them
so i figured out i said you know what
i'm not going to walk here anymore
because all the breathing by that time
there was no mask
people were still looking for masks
whatever
i stopped going there i don't know what
the end of the point of the story was
you were thinking about jiu jitsu when
they started
when it started because right away how
are you gonna do jiu jitsu
how the [ __ ] are you gonna do jiu jitsu
with without breathing on somebody
sweating on somebody so i think that
there's gonna be a couple states they're
to be hesitant
california might be one of them that it
can't happen it because
california is basically the apex of the
best
jiu jitsu in this country that's the
mecca now it's the
world so i think jiu jitsu schools
really have to have a plan
and tax showers at the facility
you know whatever it is no showers at
the facility yeah you can't take a
shower at the facility whatever it takes
to
convince the people to open it up it's
about filmmaking
after this a few months we'll see where
it goes right
we also have to take a study of how many
from everybody marcelo garcia
uh or samurai uh
whatever the truth an honest assessment
of how many of their students
they're big house schools like alberto
crane
you know marcelo garcia's look at his
schedule
it starts at six in the morning with
whatever they go till
ten o'clock at night so you have to
assume how many people going in there
what's it gonna be cut down to you know
these are all things and at the end you
want me to tell you what this all comes
down to
pay cut we're getting the [ __ ] pay
cut
life's not going to be as normal as it
was
i don't give a i don't give a i don't
give a [ __ ] i'm doing what i want to do
anyway
so you know stand up
i'll wait uh you know you can't wait
if they only tell you to open up with
eight students
and eight includes you no parents
at the kids things either
parents just drop them off now you know
again this is all you you know let's see
all the things that you see well it's uh
definitely a stressful situation
you know it's stressful but it isn't
it's stressful
but it isn't what things you have you
have
one two three
four five six opportunities a day to
train
that's basically and then on saturdays
it's two and then on sundays it's
one if there's a school that you want to
join
you can't make an excuse up about not
training there
because they start back up at 6 30 and
they go to 9 30 next thing you know
you're dancing with a bunch of savages
with a string drinking coconut water
alberto's doing [ __ ] copper
but it's such a it's such a
if you know the people from there
it's such a family community old school
martial art you know you go to most
martial arts schools now
jiu jitsu from 11 to 1. go there at 115.
there's not a soul there
that does mean no good that does mean
when i was a kid
karate man was there all day he lived in
the back there was a little thing
you could hear him [ __ ] little
chinese chick he brought back from
vietnam
because most guys that talked karate
when i was a kid they came back from
vietnam they brought their own little
china ching chuk
they brought their own little hoon and
back back
and they would be back there [ __ ] and
suck and he come out with his [ __ ] up
gear
how can i help you you know
first of all by [ __ ] washing your
teeth
you smell like nah but what i'm saying
is
you have a full service place there's
times i'm going to flappers
and they're still mopping the floors at
10 o'clock at night
this isn't a guy that is a hobbyist jiu
jitsu that's
monday through 5 friday he's a fire man
this is a guy that he wants you to walk
in there a white belt
knowing nothing he doesn't give a [ __ ]
that's even better the less you know the
better don't tell him that
i'm going to get in shape for a month
he'll get you in shape
and he'll walk you out of that black
belt more ways than one
you know so i feel it's a pillar
of the community you have to write that
all down in your pitch
because they're going to come into every
business and say
ah this and this recommendation
and you're either going to have to take
it or go excuse me
let me explain to you what what have you
i went to the university of new mexico
my cousin's a thing an anti-biologist
he says if i spray this at night it
takes 12 hours
and it gets from looking crannies blah
blah blah because of that i could extend
it the tactical fitness room
instead of having 12 i'll cut it down to
eight people and then it's your time to
become monty or
you got to cut a deal for every student
you get and then you adjust
i like these people i'm going to open up
even if they don't [ __ ] do it okay
open up god forbid the kid does get kobe
now who's gonna sue you you'll be
[ __ ] teaching
japanese [ __ ] brazil and in in mexico
with the the
guy from [ __ ] the sweaty yoga place
that was fingering chicks
while they were doing yoga what's his
name vikram
[ __ ] you'll be doing yoga down
there with him covered yoga
do two weeks oh man what and i know it's
not the same but
you guys are talking about it is do you
see a benefit from doing the online
classes
like maybe someone from out of town can
can do it or for sure for sure like you
know
like speaking of the silver lining like
we set up a whole legacy
academy on you know a dot online you
know so we have
you know myself and all of our like
amazing coaches and professors we have
like uh training modules and just a
library of information they can access
now you know
and then of course we have the whole
virtual schedule with zoom
zoom classes he watches the facebook
facebook live you know
so there's no there's no interaction i
ignore i ignore the the the facebook
the facebook live a little bit so you
like man look at the camera like
talk to me just cry smile it's supposed
to be exercise
and his sister he looks at the [ __ ]
clock what are you copernicus
get up do a jumping jack they can't in
between
he got me he got me uh so every i mean i
make sure i make sure i uh i get up and
i
do stuff and then he'll be on a roll
then he'll do all this
and he's got me going and he does his
waist
then it's like he forgets
he's watching he's not doing it if
you're doing it i'm doing it
he's on the couch now i'm waiting for
the next [ __ ] move
i gotta do it on my [ __ ] [ __ ]
laptop
okay the ipad and i thought the ipad i
can get facebook so no
so i gotta do it in my office which is
better it works great
so at 12 o'clock 10 to 11. i'll sit
there and i'll start with him writing
because it takes eight minutes you know
he's got to look around the room
make sure he calls me up and yells at me
the first thing he was doing jiu jitsu i
got birdo why are you doing jiu jitsu
who am i gonna choke the cat he's over
there take the arm
put it behind the leg who are you gonna
choke why are you doing [ __ ] jiu
jitsu
and the worst part on
so i started doing the squats with him i
do all my
whatever with him he still hasn't broken
out the metal
i still can't last that long because he
disappears
where you at it's 12 25. you were great
we did the wrist we did the shoulders we
did the thing
we did the back laying down kicking you
know we did about 10 of those kicking
things like this
all right what's next i don't know how
berlo left
so now i got to go in the morning to see
what [ __ ] rob miller's teaching
rob militia's a big class but rob miller
is a strong guy
and he starts with these bats that
[ __ ] minky mantle can hold
mickey mantle couldn't pick up three of
these things rob miller's in there doing
twitter up stop just get attention
why are you making me as soon as i feel
rob miller i'm like i don't want to
watch this no more
he's like superhero over there swinging
another guy
he takes text messages looks at the
chinese girl walking across the street
pay attention get on there do those
swings so i know what i'm doing
oh but it's so much that you offer
that in these times nobody would offer
anything yeah
and all day long we got it going on the
zoom the zoom is nice because
you can interact with people you can be
like do this do that nah but you don't
want to interact with nobody just do
this and shut your mouth
just shut your mouth that's a sign right
on the bottom
either do it or go [ __ ] hang out with
with the beat diddy
this is my class do it like this
the only thing that you can't do the
only thing you could do with zoom
because especially with tactical fitness
it's that an inch of the movement of the
foot
could make such a difference when i
swing the bats i can just swing them
but alberto taught me to swing him in
to get that full stretch so when i come
out
i'm swinging out with myself shoulders
so that's the thing where you do need
just that to be there with him that's it
because after a year if you're doing it
then you finally go see alberto
you're like i threw a year away from not
twisting that's he didn't see the twist
with with
with tactical fitness there's a lot of
little twists
and key little things like i warm up
with the boom with the throw out that's
my warm-up
boom but i also focus on this
this is for a long time i wasn't
focusing on this
this has to be locked quarter position
okay this has to be locked
in push out again
locked this has to be locked i was a
[ __ ] i would do the swings
and i kept doing 10. i go how am i going
to stay at i'm going to stay at 10th on
90.
so what i did was i started getting the
15s
and just making sure that i held them
perfect for form perfect form
and lock my body in breathe let
out spin perfect form the first time i
did the other one
where you bow and you [ __ ] that's a
little confusing at first
the first time you hit you here i don't
care if you're einstein
there's one ear bang it's like when you
do new checks the first time
first time you practice new trucks you
go home with a bump what happened
i'll tell you at dinner mickey will tell
you
i have a bunch of friends like i i'm
surrounded by people who do
do do do do sorry and like
a few weeks ago i saw on instagram like
they would meet in a garage
and like watch like speaking videos of
clubs yeah like they watch videos of
like tournaments and they try to
recreate it
they just meet up and they just train
you know on their own it's very
interesting
and listen i'm not mad at people
i can't get mad at you for doing that
okay but you're doing that in somebody's
house
obviously you're doing in grandma's
house grandma don't even know what jiu
jitsu
is she's upset watching maury povich
you know waiting for oprah because she
hates black people but she loves oprah
and you're downstairs doing [ __ ]
killing your son you know breathing
and someday one kid's gonna go up there
breathe on grandma
you don't know that grandma had
hepatitis
you know whatever i don't [ __ ] know
you know
listen why do i wear a mask i wear a
mask because
i know where i've been i know where i've
been
i've been on 2 000 flights the last ten
years
if i know you know and these flights
these people
should be ashamed of themselves i've
seen i've been there where people get
off a plane
and they will say okay boarding
they don't even hear out the plan you're
going right back into the [ __ ] germs
yeah so i'm avoiding everything i saw
years ago
filthy all that [ __ ] we laughed about a
couple weeks ago
putting your foot on the screen well
you have your sneakers off on a plane
disgusting
you take your toe you go on a plane with
flip well first of all if you're a man
and you're a flip flop
you lost a fight against me i don't care
how many martial arts you know
because the first thing i'm doing for my
gorilla heel with bursitis
i got a little burst of ball that stings
you like a beehive
i will step on the middle of your foot
that before you throw a punch you will
drink 10 times about it and then i will
grab your dick and
pull up and squeeze down at the same
time and not even takasaki
get out of that move you understand me
that's the old
uncle joey twister eddie bravo can bang
his head go to brazil
nobody can get out of that one oh you
don't even know what it risks to pull on
first
a foot squeezing you and the other guy i
think i'd go after the day one
you breathing in his ear how long do you
think this is gonna last
before your dick gets ripped off
anyway i'm sorry i get dark thoughts
that's the thing man we gotta get we
gotta get back into i don't know man
sooner or later like got back to what
what we're gonna just hide out for
what's
what's this well you have a good
standing with burbank
you have a really good standing with
burbank you're a majority business owner
in burbank
you have to sit down with your
teachers tomorrow or saturday and go
let's set the guidelines
you have to look at your schedules we
might have to add a few classes
on it you know for sure yeah take a few
classes off if you're not doing anything
sure sure and uh it's the safety of your
i want to know the thing
the thing with la though right the la
county there's not even a date
for opening right that's the crazy thing
you know
like the governor is at least talking
about you know
phase three hopefully you know one of
these days you know
but again i'm an actor and i'm a hustler
okay
you tell me that there's three kilos of
our cocaine
but it's stuck in the house in mexico
okay we could sit here and wait for the
helicopter to come
or you busy not really you busy
let's go pick it up ourselves okay so
what i want you to do or any jamon or
any prospective owner is no for sure
we're already
yeah yeah act as if they didn't open i
didn't say they opened up your store
don't say joey d has told you no go to
your business
put some x's on the floor take the
plexiglass
put holes in it put it over the register
leave the gap
in the bottom uh go for the hand
sanitizer
not the russian one it's already got
[ __ ] uh osama blood in it you gotta
get an american one
and you gotta have a plan for them and
then they'll come in and meet you
halfway
at least they're not coming in telling
you
i need a handicapped bathroom now people
sure
that's it you know what if they come in
and go not only do i need a [ __ ] for
bad
[ __ ] a bathroom for handicapped now
i need to attract a bathroom
covered people i mean i'm not saying
this is gonna happen right
something similar i want people to
understand that
you're just not going back everybody's
losing 25 percent
you're losing 25 if you're a weight
staff
they're cutting half the tables if
you're a movie theater that couldn't
have the thing if the dodgers play you
don't have to sit next to joey if he's
got armpit smell
you got three seats they're gonna have
to give it to you
and you're gonna have to sign stuff and
there's gonna be
thermometer checks and if you get it do
i sue
alberto crane there if i go to alberto
crane
school and i get jiu jitsu do i school
up
no that's why every city is looking for
traces to send alberto down and go
alberto let's do this
when did you get off the plane from
brazil sunday where'd you go
i got an uber what was the uber's name
abdul
where'd he drop you off why'd you eat
dinner who'd you get contact with
you know that's what's gonna happen now
they're gonna come back to you and
they're gonna really shut you down
yeah i mean it's interesting how you
brought up the plane
example and the reason was it for that i
think
is because people get upset and start
yelling why is my plan late why is it
not taking off and like
i think a lot of this i blame us as
people
because i think that's part of the
schedule from now we schedule
a plane lands at 10 40. it can't take
off till 11 30.
that has to be a mandatory cleaning you
know not to be at the airport until 10
30 anyway
while you're [ __ ] landing and going
through your thing
they should be cleaning off the [ __ ]
plane right but i'm talking about small
business owners right now in america
right who are suffering i'm suffering
with you
so i'm telling you right now but i
closed this [ __ ] shop down
no i can't do live to live thank god i
don't give a [ __ ] he does tac fit and
he's got an immune system of a crackhole
he can lick a [ __ ] sidewalk and spit
in your face nobody's you know
uh people if you have a business
my brother owns a framing shop in new
jersey
i love him with all my art i said you're
not open
but what if you wanted to sat there with
one of the lights on
what if i know lots of people that are
giving haircuts
and then their backyards and their you
know in their businesses you know
they have people come through the back
thank god i'm losing my hair
the middle piece hasn't grown but the
sides i just buzzed it like a [ __ ]
puerto rican
yeah i buzzed it and i got a big patch
on and then i had to put crazy glue over
it and shoot apology
but no seriously listen i need a haircut
i'm going to wait till the law goes
legit i want to come to tack fit
i want to wait till it's all yeah i mean
that's the thing
that's the thing because you feel like
well when are we gonna open up alberto
professor open that door just a little
time
how bad would you feel how bad would you
feel
okay
spikes are rising in texas spikes are
rising in georgia
this weekend alberto crank can have a
barbecue if he wants he's an american
only one thing don't invite nobody you
got enough [ __ ] kids
and your wife's got a sister she's got
kids and you know everybody's got kids
with y'all
media that's it you know
you still got to be vigilant i don't
care what you believe what the
scientific
evidence says i really don't care i know
what the scientific evidence says if you
touch something now they're saying
if you don't touch ten dicks and nothing
happens
no covenant that's what they're saying
now
that was the big thing at the beginning
just don't go into a [ __ ] bar and do
blow and [ __ ] get breathed on
by johnny black's moves who's been
playing the bass for 29 years
and did time for 18 of them and you'll
be fine
act as if yeah i mean you got to be
careful but i mean
i think that that seems like there's a
lot of people who are being careful get
sick i think it's just
i don't know now you have ms publicly
known
multiple sclerosis yeah does that is
that an underlying condition
so what's ms it uh your immune system
attacks basically like your nervous
system right so yeah i could have
complications
but what do i do i do tack fit i take
care of my health
i am like super proactive you know what
do you think that's going to do to my
immune system
what do you think that's going to be to
my overall nervous system and everything
else
so and you don't think the mindset
affects that you know think about like
talk about the
you know let's talk about the immune
system right with this whole fight or
flight like all this fear on the news
what's going on it's suppressing it's
suppressing our immune system
it's almost like they want us to get
sick what about in new york the governor
comes out and he says
66 percent of the people with that
covenant 19 the new people
they've all been under you know they've
been home quarantined how does that
happen
they're all scared they're all like you
know not doing stuff right
they're not exercising they're not doing
things that so they're
and they're not mixing we got to mix
germs man you know that's that's our
immune system right
that's how it responds and that's how it
adapts and that's how we stay strong and
so we stay healthy
you know little kid you want him to you
know walk around on the you know crawl
around on the ground and you know put
stuff in his mouth like if we're not
doing those things like
i mean it's like a recipe for disaster
what about a second wave comes what if
this other thing comes
we're not going to be prepared for it
you know what if jesus makes us come
back
a lot of things exactly we don't know we
still got to live our lives that's it
we've got to live we've got to get
people out there working yeah
i got americans out there that's it
that's it i watched the uh
the fox plant in detroit opened up as
they were walking in
people were saying we're not ready
this is [ __ ] and they try to omit it
they had to close the plant within 24
hours they got three new cases because
we're not prepared yet as americans
for ten and over something goes on when
there's ten and over
there's a situation i can't stop
thinking about
michael yo jimmy big balls
jeffrey gullian and chris missiley
in the same setting like this one night
until
one in the morning just talking the next
day
three out of the four of them ended up
in the hospital for weeks
nothing happened to the fourth guy you
know
what did he do differently why is the
immune system meant that way
these are all questions i have do i
think it exists
and exist do i think it's lightening
down
yes it is we don't have the dense
population new york has
so i think here in california we're okay
right now
disneyland's still not open watch
disneyland's lead
if they're not open then you shouldn't
be open
they know something you don't know so
uh kickboxing now becomes exercise
you and i can't face each you and i
can't face each other
that's it we can't face each other we
got a stagger
start with a five pound bag boom boom a
five pound weight
throw kicks now you could throw kicks in
front of a bag
if you had six bags now you have to have
four
because of the six foot distancing the
this is what's going to change in gyms
what uh you know like sweden right like
they never close up right
and then there's like you know these
german scientists these doctors right
everybody's like hurting me
talking about herd immunity right so
what about that
what about that that that way is that a
better way
i think the the scary part is is we're
finding out even the doctors
don't really know what the best way to
do this is but you know
if we don't know what's what's the
what's the choice right to live in fear
or to live your life of course be
being careful being precautious i live
in fear and i'm careful at the same time
it's like i live like being a drug
dealer having a million dollars in your
pocket
and you got a gun in your pocket they're
they're behind every bush
yeah don't think they're not saying yeah
don't think that chick that's
half topless looking for a ride home
it's there for a reason they're gonna
knock you the [ __ ] off
so you're always looking you know you're
still not touching doorknobs
you're still washing your hands you're
still well you were you
actually like that was my point or like
i've seen a lot of videos the last
week or so of people just being [ __ ]
like yelling at people
grocery store people and then the
grocery stores they're on edge but then
they
find out that rock and roll ralph's had
30 employees test positive for kobe
and people who went in there a lot of
people when they
say now well what about all those people
on home depot or costco right yeah so
that's i that's what i'm saying i think
if the reason it's gone on so long is
because there's a lot of people not
doing anything
because in theory there's the guys
[ __ ] yeah we say [ __ ] it
with this heat i get vitamin d every day
i breathe
i ride a bicycle outside at first i was
trying to do the right thing
putting the [ __ ] mask on you can't
ride no bike with a mask on
you gotta breathe fresh air yeah just
keep your throat
[ __ ] draw because of the attacks you
throw when you're dry
so that's why they they said do you
really have to be
what's the word human
hydrated because that's what attacks you
the most
likely if i leave here i'll go home and
gargle with hot water
just because i had contact with you i'm
not going to be mad at you because i
think i'm
i think i have the antibodies also i
flew
that weekend but anyway getting to all
this [ __ ]
uh you and your when the first time that
you came in the podcast
you spoke about dedicating your life to
jiu jitsu moving
getting the support from your family
living in a
a shed getting your black belt from
margalina or whatever his name
chuckling draculino
uh you you fought for jackson out of
whatever
yeah i was his first uh mma champion
unbelievable you run a major you know as
king of the cage was which was a big
deal back in the day right
yes it was back in the day you fought in
the ufc
then you said [ __ ] it yes you did a
couple other fights and then
you discovered that you enjoyed teaching
you were gracie baja for a while
you told them to go away they don't pay
you you got to pay them you know what
i'm saying like you don't [ __ ] around
alberto crane but
and you create a legacy and it's become
when you see those lunchtime pictures it
breaks your heart because you sought
from 20 people
to 40 to 60 the people mailing
people hanging from raptors you have
women's self-defense
but you have something that nobody has
in the area
and it's something that like
people my age yeah i can put a gui on
and go to jiu jitsu
but how much practicality am i going to
get from jiu-jitsu i'm going to go
twice a week and be sure the rest of the
time and then
every 90 days pull something
yeah i can go to kickboxing that's a
great exercise
but at this age right now 57 you get the
[ __ ]
not the scoliosis you get the other one
where that's less
the muscle deteriorates after 40.
you have [ __ ] that you can't a year and
a half ago i couldn't shoot a basket
do you know now i could shoot a basket
with my daughter i can't do a 20-footer
but i can do a three-footer because of
those bats
that i mean that's the thing that's
that's the part of like you know the
jiu-jitsu like that's why i'm so
passionate about tac fit right because
it gave me that ability you know i meet
myself and i have so many injuries and
the
mass diagnosis like i couldn't put my
seatbelt on you know i was in bad shape
and i was
just like you know everything hurt to
move so i just want to stay in bed you
know i was in really bad shape i didn't
act like it people didn't maybe know but
that was the reality you know
and little by little the more i did like
the tactical you know moving the neck
the into flow and all the stuff that we
do
things started to change within me you
know and all the students that do it
you see the same things happening you
know and so
yeah i mean that's that's the key is to
have that a part of your training you
know but i think martial arts you've
been the martial arts your whole life
right since you're a kid
and so i think we never i never got
taught those things you know
like that mr miyagi put his hands
together right and uh
and uh healed danny's son's shoulders
right so that i think that should be
part of the martial arts
uh that that healing component or you
know healing yourself at least right
to understand your body just the
awareness right to so you can
so you can what's a typical week so
people know i remember once you broke it
down for me that monday was
heavy you know it's really it's really
you know the way
scott sonnen has it he has like a wave
he has a four day wave like no intensity
you know low intensity yeah uh high
he way he waves it you know so it's like
different intensity so i think just to
keep that in mind you know because
everybody's lifestyle is a little bit
different you know
and so maybe one day but not training
hard every day you know but
switching it up you know and you can
change that up you can use that in jiu
jitsu for example like one day
okay i'm going to train a little bit
more maybe today i'm not going to train
i'm just going to do technique and
i'm going to move my body you know i'm
going to you know do the warm up do what
i would focus on other things
you know so i think i think just kind of
waving it waving it
and uh and uh you know doing the same
things
as ta as the you know with the wave of
tack fit keeps everything like
in in check you know so you know and
you're asking about the tac fit
when we have the first we have money
shoes and wednesday it's like more like
kind of like different time protocols
like a little bit harder you know
there's always
we do a flow and friday we do a
technique day where we break down
complex components and make it like
simple so you learn it
and this saturday we're back you know
but you can make it whatever you want
you know for example for myself maybe i
train hard jiu jitsu
the day before so if i do tack for the
next morning i'm going to use it
even on those hard ones i make it easier
myself i go lighter in weight i go lower
lower rep count you know
and i use that that workout to recover
so you can make it whatever you want
because you can scale it to how you want
and how we when what you need
how many cities is attack building now
and you know like there was a growing
because i know that
i saw that this week you had like guests
[ __ ]
yeah so we got some yes coaches is a new
uh is our new like us director you know
so he's uh he's doing a lot
and he's been in the system like back
since back in the day back and before i
even attacked the name tagford existed
so he's like oh gee you know
and so um what was the question like who
how many how many there's there's
coaches all over there's there's people
all over the world practicing it
but there was no organization you know
and so we're trying to organize it and
make it better you know but there's
people and all like man around the world
china school in jersey uh there's a
there's a there's a
there's not a school but i want to help
with that you know i want to help that
because that's what i see
there's people that are that are
certified that that are coaches but
there's no stack with schools and that's
the future that's what i see that's what
i want to see you know
like i believe in the community i know
we're doing the social distancing thing
and
all the stuff is going on but i mean for
us to live our best life i believe in
that you know and that's what keeps you
in check that's
it even you like guys maybe they don't
do the zoom class but they see like the
facebook lives going on
and it makes them like okay cool there's
some normalcy going on we hustled we
went
we went there right away right without
hesitation joe frazier joey myself
robert we got on there on zoom right
on facebook live right away we're doing
classes and we got it going on
coach andy uh you know we have it going
on all press of joy right we all day
long all day long we're doing it so
it was important you know just uh a lot
of people don't know what to do
a lot of people didn't even have club
bells yeah but they got to see what you
were doing and going you know what man
maybe when things open up i'll start
going over there maybe
how many of your students have been
keeping in touch
i don't like doing the classes i mean a
lot you know it's uh
we try to connect and you know our
community's strong i lent out a bunch of
our
our club bells and kettlebells and you
know even some like these heavy bags
that we use for like
you know they're kind of like dummies
you know jiu jitsu dummies so we lent
them out just to support everybody you
know so they could follow along with the
classes and have their own tools because
actually kettlebells and actually the
club bells that we have for the tag for
two like both they're sold
out in a lot of places you know most
places everywhere everywhere yeah
everywhere
bicycles everybody became rocky balboa
yeah everybody was drake though it's
unbelievable all the gyms are closed
right
yeah so i read that article that you
couldn't get a bicycle
it was crazy i was like is this true and
i went the guy who's like we don't have
no bikes here until
wednesday i told my neighbor he goes i
want it for you
for tomorrow next day he brought me a
bike i had to go buy a seat for it i've
been riding the bike ever since
tremendous it's tremendous and stuff now
you have
you have a uh work uh
wrestlers so
so it's like it's kind of for beginners
and now we had talked about
you know you know being your best at
every age and so it's a thing it's a
tool like
obviously like my niche or my my life
has been jiu jitsu so i definitely have
jiu jitsu people in mind for this you
know because i want people to be able to
train i believe in jiu jitsu as a tool
for you to be your best you know
and so it's it's it's something that
helps you
you know stay healthy for you know for
you know
every decade right to stay healthy you
know and so it's it's
you know you should have that i believe
that you should be part of your training
speaking about having that ability to
heal yourself and
just understand yourself better but it's
for everybody
anybody can use it you know anybody can
use it and
i try to do it as basic as i can you
know but it's good for advanced people
because there's some details and i
talk about my experience you know and uh
you know but it's called the grapples
toolbox 101 coming out on
attackfit.com you know next week next
thursday
so i'm really excited about that because
uh i get to contribute you know to
something that's really done a lot for
me
i'm really a good man you have a good
school over there
like i said it's not a school or an
academy
it's a little family and i spoke to
marco
you know i know a lot of guys i hurt
because that's all they got yeah they
really
they really uh that's all they got you
know i bumped into a gym owner
at a supermarket i don't want to say
with his name he's a real [ __ ]
run and he was telling me how they got
to open this gym because governor newsom
is getting sued
and i had to like look at him and go are
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you can't be this [ __ ] stupid he's
brazilian taboo
he's like no they have to my friend says
they're going to sue governor newsom we
open up the lady next week and i'm like
you can't be this [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're in no danger he's still making
videos of him on the beach
ufc one who gives a [ __ ] you know what
i'm saying
what the [ __ ] is wrong with these people
always a pleasure having you alberto
thank you always a pleasure knowing
you're there uh
you have two schools glendale which is
great
and legacy in burbank and uh
whatever you need muay thai girls
self defense [ __ ] kettlebells at 5 30
in the morning
and then they do jiu jitsu afterwards
that's crazy bastard
uh you know jiu jitsu starts at 5 30.
if you got kids that can't behave
themselves bring them to alberto
within a month they'll be all right
it'll be choked the [ __ ] out
we ship them out the back door over
there it's over what happened we don't
know
they left with a [ __ ] armenian family
see you later all right
bye and that's it that's that real quick
let me read you something all right i
want to thank the maestro jujitsu
alberto crane who knows when jiu-jitsu
is coming back
it's the opposite of social distancing
what are you gonna do hold on let me see
if i can get this fly
let me see if i still got it this year i
can't be held back
am i going to get him am i going to get
him i'm going to get him i'm going to
get him am i going to go
i got this [ __ ] there he is
right there
live and in color who the [ __ ] you think
you're dealing with where's the light
saw you [ __ ] sucker
dad take some of that you [ __ ] i thought
you have to come in here no more isn't
that
your little [ __ ] covered [ __ ] sucker
i gotta spray some [ __ ] lights on
my hands now i'm still the best fly
swatter in north america when it comes
to swatting the fly
nobody gets them like uncle joey i hate
those [ __ ] look at him he's
like mr miyagi
look i'm not gonna cut off like i gotta
[ __ ] light him on fire
you know he's on fire funny you fly
people
want to complain you want to call the
ambulance as a fly on fire in my [ __ ]
office right now
anyway i want to thank alberto crane i
want to thank this [ __ ] fly
and i want to thank you guys for always
having my back and supporting the
podcast
all right have a great weekend uh we'll
see you monday morning tip-top magoo
ready to go stay black kick this mu lee
[Music]
you